now you did have the internet and quite
the frenzy though when you said you were
taking a sabbatical after production on
this film I'm your Ghost of Christmas
presents
Like A Christmas Carol you are now back
in production on things filming so how
long did you ultimately take and what
was the best part of this little Hiatus
for you it was pretty I took a year off
really um yeah a little over a year
um and it was just great I just love
being home with my family and you know
taking the kids to school and just being
I have so many other aspects in my life
that keep me busy but they can but being
busy at home is much different than
being busy and like you know
I get it Chicago right London and it
seems like you've been busy with the
friends friendship bracelets too oh yeah
my daughters love to love to make Daddy
bracelets yeah I love it and fans are
awesome probably tracking devices
actually now that I think about
this is where real change begins
Oh that's oh he's dead yeah he's
definitely no no he's fine he's good
you've said a few different times that
you weren't sure a few years ago if you
were ready to take on a film quite as
challenging as this one yeah so what
changed what allowed you to become
prepared to serve as a triple threat
sing and dancing acting here well I I
think I'm more comfortable as I've
gotten older I'm more comfortable
sucking at stuff you know and I really
don't believe that you can't really be
good at something unless you're willing
to suck at it
um so you know it's it's that there's an
old adage you say in stunts which also
applies to dancing which is you know um
uh it's slow is smooth smooth is fast
yeah and that's what it was for dancing
just start off slow and then you move on
to smooth and then you can start to go
fast and we just super patient we're
getting those smooth Vibes in there yeah
fans are tracking everything that is
going on in the Deadpool three worlds
yeah your biggest rival Hugh Jackman
he's back he's swore for years he was
never going to portray Wolverine again
but somehow you convinced him how did
you do it I wish I had a Magic Touch
like that I did not convince them
whatever that was all him I've been I've
yes I've been asking him to do it for
six straight years but it was ultimately
you that yeah it was ultimately Hue that
said oh you know I think I am ready to
come back and and all we had to do was
sell it to Kevin feige which didn't take
long the next thing you knew here we are
oh my God so good so good and finally I
got you and I gotta let you in on a
little fan Theory that's circulating
right now okay Deadpool three and All
Too Well were filmed in the same
location so fans out there are
speculating now that that's a little
Golden Nugget and Easter egg if you will
that Taylor Swift is going to make a
cameo in the next Deadpool film well if
we shoot the next Deadpool film in our
house then that would be that location
okay well would you ship it if Taylor
makes a cameo at all of course yeah
kidding me I would do anything for that
woman she's the genius she is indeed are
you bump into midnight 24 7. all of us
whole house I'm not kidding I love it so
much like I do Blake does my daughter's
who love it
[Music]